2022 has come to an end in what a year
it has been and not just for the games
but for us the gamers filled with plenty
of highs and lows so many that it can be
a little hard to recount all of them so
I'm going to do my best to wrap the
whole year up for you by setting a scene
picture this you're a gamer in the year
2022. it's January New Year New You and
after a couple years of being locked up
inside your aspiration setting has been
knocked down to more achievable goals
just kidding you get coveted on New
Year's Day after dodging it since 2020.
and now all you do is Watch X-Files
everything in your life becomes an
X-File
[Music]
meanwhile you hear that take two the
parent company of Grand Theft Auto
announces its acquisition of Zynga for
12.7 billion dollars it's so much money
that it's the biggest acquisition in
gaming history it's gonna be a long time
until anyone matches that that's for
damn sure Microsoft announces its
acquisition of Activision for 68.7
billion
billion 70 billion dollars for a video
game company the CEO of Activision Bobby
cotec Rambles a bunch about something
called the metaverse we talk about the
metaverse all the time but I have to
admit I don't really understand it I
don't know what it means me neither lady
however you realize that when the deal
goes through Microsoft will be the proud
owners of phantasma gory
[Music]
and a bunch of other stuff I guess
just when you thought companies had run
out of all the money in the world to buy
things Sony announces its plans to
acquire Bungie for 3.6 billion dollars
okay but really companies are finally
done spent New York Times announces that
it's acquired Wordle you might have
heard of it for an undisclosed seven
figures games are released but you don't
remember any of them because the only
thing making headlines is the disgusting
amount of money being spent and to think
it is only January
oh in Pokemon Arceus Arceus whatever a
new Pokemon game comes out you buy it
and play it for 10 hours straight like
you do every single Pokemon game and
then never return to it ever again you
swear you'll never buy a Pokemon game
ever again but you're still very happy
for everyone else who's enjoying it it's
February that Hong Kong martial arts
action game sifu made by a French Studio
that directly uses a South Korean film
references comes out that's cool instead
you boot up Jackie Chan stuntmaster
don't make me laugh Vita turns 10. you
play it for the first time in your
scolded by your peers where were you 10
years ago at first you don't really get
it until you you play Persona 4 Golden
and then you absolutely definitely get
it Horizon forbidden West or
is it zero Dawn
that's no that's the first one
right
anyways Horizon forbidden dawned West is
released it's big it's beautiful good
thing there's nothing coming out to
detract it from its technological Beauty
like breath of the wild did back in 2017
with whatever the first one was called
Elden ring is released you forget about
all other games that exist it takes over
your life all you can do is think about
Elden ring all you can do is play Elden
ring your life becomes Elden ring on the
very same day as Elden ring the steam
deck is released and slowly starts to
make its way into people's eager hands
and you're happy for them because you
find its size repulsive
it's March tuna comes out and everyone
who plays it desperately tries to
convince you that it is more than a
Zelda clone but no one is capable of
saying why other than saying you just
have to play it GD happens and it's back
in person for the first time since 2019
suck it kovid you go to the awards
ceremony in a big room with actual
breathing human beings you may or may
not have gone completely intoxicated and
woke up the next morning contemplating
your social choices you hear about a
game called Norco but you're too caught
up in all your friends chatting about
the game with the giant mouthful mode
what are we talking about here it's
April and it sure is good to finally see
games coming out on the regular now that
every single Studio spent all their
money buying everything Nintendo makes a
big old acquisition of land they spent
40 million dollars on just
plant
okay
the play date is released move over
steam deck there's another root and two
in handheld in these here parts and it's
not a big bulky heavy hot piece of
Machinery like you in fact it's the
furthest thing imaginable can you fit a
steam deck in your pocket no does the
steam deck have a novelty crank to play
one big games no yeah that's what I
thought wait jinko jeans came back in
style this year you can fit a steam deck
in your pocket
you set the play date on your shelf to
appreciate its Sleek little coolness and
then forget you even have Nintendo
switch Sports it's sad alone but it's
great with friends you go back to the
office after a long Hiatus because of
covid-19 and get extremely aggressive
about it people are having a great time
being around people is a great time
Resident Evil 4 VR gets mercenaries mode
and you once again get to pretend you're
Leon S Kennedy could feel like an
absolute badass even if you look like an
absolute idiot
meanwhile you're playing the silver case
for the very first time and you become
absolutely obsessed so what if it's a 23
year old game
an embracer group acquires assets from
Square Enix including Crystal Dynamics
idos Montreal and Square Enix Montreal
this means Tomb Raider and Deus Ex and
blah blah blah whatever I get it people
are buying stuff people are just
constantly buying stuff meanwhile you
finally 5 months and 218 episodes later
finish X-Files and then immediately
start playing The X-Files FMV game for
the PS1 so what if it's a 24 year old
game E3 2022 is officially canceled rip
to an industry pillar rip also to all
the characters in The Quarry although
you don't care what happens to anyone in
the game except for Susan Sarandon's son
who you also learn is Tim robbins's kid
and then maybe you wonder what it's like
to have them as your parents and feel a
sense of
be anime fans and speedrunning junkies
Rejoice neon white is out summer game
Fest happens in person you're in a
studio talking about it with real people
Dead Island 2 isn't so dead because it
finally gets a trailer and a release
date that's definitely coming out
absolutely when it says it's going to
power wash simulator our lives are
blessed with making monotony a game
design in all our real life monotonous
troubles fade away as we don't address
them to instead rid a playground from
dirt and grime video games are great
real life responsibilities aren't or you
can make really difficult life choices
in as dusk Falls now I'm going to draw a
penis on this dude's driveway instead
stray it's the cat game cats love the
game it has you asking questions like
have you ever wondered what it's like to
be a cat an old game comes out as a new
game and it's live of live live a live
live alive alive it's August you hear
about one of those companies buying
something and you just don't care
anymore anyways call of the Lamb it's
cozy does creepy multiverses its WB does
smash rollerdrome it's Mad Max letter
Dome does Tony Hawk Saints Row does
Saints throw
then immortality comes out and at first
you think you're just scrubbing through
a bunch of movie footage and you think
it's really cool and then something
happens and it blows your [ __ ] mind
it's September remember when Jeff Keeley
buried E3 in the ground and replaced it
with the summer game Fest while E3 is
back from the grave and it's coming for
us all in summer 2023. oh but don't
worry summer game Fest is also happening
in 2023. Tokyo game show happens in
person you go there in person you play
like a dragon Edition in person you get
your face scanned to the rgg studio in
person and do all the Japanese things
you're supposed to do and feel cool in
person and then you realize that maybe
you weren't physically designed for some
of the places in the city in person can
we talk about how cheap Retro games are
in Japan
maybe in another video holy [ __ ] this
copy of enemy zero is only four dollars
what the [ __ ] The Last of Us Part One
it's a nine-year-old PS3 game that was
remastered for the PS4 but now fully
remade for the PS5 and maybe you scoffed
at its 70 price tag meanwhile you're
playing the 24 year old game Echo Night
by some company called from software on
your PS1 which goes for over 200 on eBay
twenty dollars for the Japanese version
so what if it's a 23 year old game
whatever you may or may not have
purchased a steam deck because despite
your irrational apprehension of wanting
one you knew you'd always live in a
state of curiosity or was it Envy but
then you boot up D from 1995 and you
instantly realize you've been wrong all
along you play death stranding and it
feels a little too close to home
considering the world's events over the
past two years you boot up vampire
survivors and instantly lose hours of
your life you go back to dust training
vampire survivors you play Doc to your
TV then Grim Fandango for the 97th time
you realize you can play this game then
that game you take the steam duck to bed
to breakfast you introduce it to your
parents
anyway now your switch just collects
dust until Splatoon 3 comes out and you
realize every child gamer is better than
you and you're just a wilting old man
with nothing to offer
that's okay instead you just play
phasmaphobia on your steam dike because
you're not a coward at all and you can
handle anything give us a sign
I'm out uh well good thing I have plenty
of other stuff to play like wait can't
boot up cold fear what the [ __ ] Google
announces stadia is shutting down in
January 2023. pour one out for all the
game developers who are working on
something that will never see the light
of day oh and it's October which means
games scorn gross play tale Requiem
French Mario rabbits also French Gotham
Knights Batman is dead signalus silent
hill Bayonetta 3 controversy Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2. 2009 Resident
Evil Village DLC it's fine reverse ah
it's also fine November Sonic Frontiers
releases as a Melting Pot of death
stranding Shadow of the Colossus and
Tony Hawk it makes no sense and yet it
works God of War Ragnarok comes to show
off its Epic Proportions look
okay
that was rude God of War Ragnarok that
lift can help us get higher
god of
oh okay so you're not gonna interrupt me
this time cool all right pentimen
remember how boring learning history was
not anymore because this has murder and
Dead Island 2 is delayed that's fine
it's only 12 weeks it's not like some of
us have been waiting eight years anyways
Pokemon scarlet and violet comes out
wait wasn't there already a Pokemon game
this year
what year is it anyway you don't buy it
because you've grown since January then
for just a moment you feel A tingle of
regret when you see how much fun people
are having oh my God
whatever people still love it and you're
happy for them anyways you finally
played Norco and every game that's come
before it suddenly doesn't matter except
for immortality that one can stay it's
December and survival horror is back
baby we got Resident Evil 4 remake next
year we got dead space remake coming up
we got Silent Hill 2 remake for [ __ ]
sake we have a loan in the dark remake
Alan wig 2 is expected to come next year
and what better way to kick it all off
than with the spiritual successor to
Dead Space the Callisto protocol which
just so happens to be kind of a slot
instead you stop writing this very
script to play vampire survivals
[Music]
oh
and now it's on mobile so it's all over
the game awards opportunity
for me God of War sweeps the floor and
Chris judge Kratos himself wins best
performance and gives a speech as long
as God of War Ragnarok thank you to the
game awards I have to thank my mama
my children
Corey barlog and of course atreus wasn't
there to interrupt him that time
Luke guy and the game of year game award
goes to Elder ring
and gamespot's game of the year goes to
Elder ring
20 22 has come to an end and it has been
quite the year regardless of what you
view as a higher low one thing is for
sure is that this was an exciting year
even a stepping stone for what will come
in 2023 and for me that means survival
horror so maybe it's just like a
personal thing I'm excited about or who
knows maybe it'll just mean I'll just be
playing a bunch of
30 something year old games instead
regardless I just hope that you had a
fantastic year in gaming and or your
personal life doesn't matter I just hope
you're great I hope you're feeling great
I hope you're entering the new year with
some sort of excitement or you know
living day by day whatever your heart
desires thank you for coming on this
journey with me and indulging in my
Antics to try and explain everything
that happened this year and it's without
a doubt I probably missed something
because there are a lot that there's a
there's a lot to recap all the ties and
lows all that said I'm Kurt Navina love
what you love
see you next year